we do uh we have Alice Lee Alice first
of all congratulations a difficult game
against the defending Champion Jennifer
youu but with the black pieces you did
not slow down once again pile on the
pressure and it finally paid off you
were fighting for the podium right now
tell us a bit about today's
game um yeah so I played the qg which I
don't think that expected because I
played like the slav upto um now it's in
this tournament uh so I think like uh
my position out of the opening was
pretty good um and I think I was like
kind of slowly able to play her until
this like around Before Time control
there was this like move 38 where I just
completely blundered like I like I'm
completely winning here and then here
she has Ras G7 and I was like oh I'm
like there's no way I can win this the
most I have is a
Perpetual so this is a
peret yeah and I don't have anything how
much time did she have
uh this particular she only had a minute
I think okay yeah she only had a minute
here so of course it was hard but it was
like uh yeah I mean um I was completely
winning before that so I definitely
shouldn't have blundered that um but of
course I think uh it's hard for her to
play especially in time trouble so uh I
think after this I was able to win
pretty nicely absolutely and you've done
so in a remarkable fashion you never let
go of the advantage after this
particular moment congratulations Alis I
have to say that's a good performance in
the second half of the event guys join
the conversation well you had a big you
had a bad start Alice and you had this
very very very nice comeback but two
ladies have just been doing
extraordinarily well from your
perspective what is it like uh watching
uh beum and Carissa win game after
game yeah I mean um so after my uh start
of course I had really no chance but uh
to see beum and Chris are doing so well
I mean they're obviously both in really
great shape they're playing really great
chess um and I think uh the fight for
first place will certainly be very
interesting to watch absolutely exciting
finish round 11 will be forging a new
Champion Alice uh we'll see you tomorrow
and congratulations for your win today
over the defending
Champion I thank
you she went